it's the story that's sending the
country into a frenzy and sparking
widespread conversation the president
has it what Kanye has it what are you
talking about
dragon image no and instead of focusing
on like real issues impacting race in
our country we're focusing on Kanye West
who says it's not about anything of
substance it's just all of a sudden with
a record coming out
he likes Donald Trump when the president
starts bragging about all the things
he's done for black folk Kanye West
doesn't represent black people listen to
all falls down this man has been lost
for years the african-americans are
predominantly Democrat and anytime
somebody breaks from that orthodoxy they
tend to become a target we have the
right to independent thought and I
independently think that Kanye has lost
his mind
I think it's weird I think it's
disappointing to remember he's yeah I
love it all right it was about it at the
White House press briefing the president
expressing his admiration for the
president the president has reached out
to Kanye West and whether he'd be
willing to meet with the white I know
they met during the transition that's
the only meaning I'm aware of that's
taking place or conversation president
chomp also weighing in this week he sees
that stuff and he's smart and he says
you know what Trump is doing a much
better job than the Democrats did and
president Trump commenting again today
Kanye West has performed a great service
to the black community big things are
happening in eyes are being open for the
first time in decades legacy stuff thank
you also to chance and to dr. Daryl
Scott they really get it Louis black and
Hispanic unemployment in history and
this all started with one seven word
tweet last Saturday I love the way
Candace Owens thanks that single tweet
created a media frenzy and could be
leading to a cultural shift but the five
has a very interesting update candace
predicted this would happen over a year
ago
I first said if you understand Kanye
West and you can understand the movement
of Donald Trump like it's funny that
people can't correlate that it's very
similar it's just anti political
correctness all right and joining us
today special guests on the five candor
sounds wonderful to have you here with
us we've been talking about you and now
we can speak with you finally right I've
been hearing a lot of this chatter yeah
so you predicted this a year ago and now
you become part of this cultural shift
right that's exactly right look I could
be a little biased I love the way
Candace Owens thinks as well but this is
really bizarre and I knew that it was
gonna be Kanye West to sort of break
through this matrix and this group
thought on the left because the one
thing that he advocates the most for in
his music is independence and that to be
quite frank if that is now a position a
position on the right it to be a
conservative means that you allow
independent thinking they do not allow
and I'ma left whatsoever so it's curious
to see this is this is the beginning of
what is going to be a very interesting
time in black America yeah and Greg when
this first happened we talked about it
here obviously on the five eaters they
wait something's going on here this
seems to be a cultural shift you didn't
feel it was like a publicity stunt or
anything like that well it's you know
people will call you a hypocrite if you
say well you know when celebrities talk
politics you tell them to shut up
because what do they know you're an
actor just act but this is different
because this comes with a cost it comes
with a cost to his reputation to his fan
base and album sales when people say
he's doing this to promote album sales
they don't know his fan base because
this is hurt this is going to hurt him
so we didn't choose the typical cuddly
issue that would get him love and prop
it props like climate change or or
bullying or gun control he chose the
most I mean the most harmful issue the
most divisive issue which is putting his
arms around President Trump so that
takes a lot of guts and I do think it
reflects your on Dave Rubens show there
you're seeing it you're seeing a change
also in the intellectual dark web as
they call it these shows like dave rubin
sam harris scott adams
joe rogan this there people are seeking
another place to find the truth because
they're tired of the narrative and i
think this is part of that i think
you're overstate i'm trying to overstate
it
Heraldo president President Trump got a
parole they're saying you're overstating
here's a fact that I cop to that but
here's a president I've got eight
percent eight percent of the African
American vote which was a bit of a spike
from what Mitt Romney got six percent
you know race and politics you know race
is politics politics is race in this
country Van Jones the CNN coming to
comment or a commentator said on
election night that this was white lash
there was there was white lash on one
side and there was you know a people of
color on the other side I think that is
the ferocity of the reaction to Kanye
West's support of a president Trump and
of you Candis is a measure of that I
agree because you're saying Romney was
at 6% trumps at 8% if you can go to 10
percent for a Republican candidate
nationally that brings all different
kinds of counties in play and with the
country divided the way it is I mean
that razor margin could really have a
significant impact before we start I
want to get one thing clear who what
show did you do Kanye tweeted me it was
Watters world that saw me so I just
wanted to give them a little bit of
credit here establish that Williams I'd
like to say I'm sorry
[Laughter]
really nasty he's got some bruises I
would say one thing I think Kanye and
Donald Trump have so much in common
besides the dragon energy they both
thrive on controversy they're both very
egotistical they're both loved and
they're both hated they both kind of
drive their supporters crazy but they
also make their supporters dance and he
says that this isn't political Kanye he
says it's not about Republican it's not
about Democrat it's about independent
thought and I agree with that I don't
think he's you know talking thinking
about the the black unemployment or some
of the things that that Trump has done
for the black community but if you do
think about the policy I don't think
that Trump has hurt african-americans in
this country if you look at food stamps
are down shootings are down in Chicago
historically black unemployment things
are not terrible
in the black community horrible as a
result of Donald Trump policies at
intrapersonal there is a real thing
called dragon I mean Dre and energy is
real Trump's a movie star kanye west is
a movie star there are others who have
that President Trump during the campaign
did some things that really were
egregious from the point of view of
African Americans and other minorities
when he feigned ignorance of David Duke
he did I don't know David Duke I have to
research it when he was busted in the
South Carolina primary when he in the
Charlottesville neo-nazi march when he
equated the two sides and said they're
both with the extreme right 100 right
but when it comes to neo-nazis you've
got to be unequivocal the KKK I I said
to the president face-to-face that I
thought that he needed to reach out and
and I looked around and everybody in
moral Agra was white and I said you need
some black faces here I think that
that's a reality and he has to face it
there is a structural problem with race
and politics in this country Donald
Trump because he has dragon energy
because he is this independent thinker
because he is so charismatic in his own
way has the ability I think to bust out
of that 8% Candis let me talk to you
about this because really in terms of
the this cultural shift in what's going
on here I think what and you know
minority women conservative women like
yourself like myself take offense to is
when some of the cultural elites trying
to tell us what we should think what we
should believe our ideology whether
we're on the right track or we're you
know we're just delirious to even
support a president or support
conservatives or Republicans it's pretty
much what Kanye is saying he's pushing
back against that sort of very
polarizing thinking that tries to put
people in boxes and stigmatize you if
you don't agree with what they think is
right
correct it's monolithic thinking and
that's what I've always been punching
back against because at the end of the
day doesn't always even make sense or
you bring up doesn't make sense to me
when you say he needs to have some more
black faces that means nothing we saw
that with President Obama he had every
black artist in the White House for
photo ops and at the end of the day
Chicago was war
off after eight years of Obama in office
so I don't need to see a black face I
need to see black results I mean I find
it insulting to me that people say well
let me let me pander and let you know
we've got Beyonce and jay-z on stage so
I'm with her no I'm not with her her
husband locked up more black men than
any president in the history of the
United States so you're exactly right I
find that to be always an uphill
challenge to say to somebody lawsuit
yeah her husband prosecutor I'll tell
you you can see that in terms of the
number and a record level of
incarceration of a black American so you
know there's points to be made here with
specific facts to support all of these
you know these theories of people saying
wait a second what's going on in this
country that all of a sudden there's a
groupthink
that's trying to pollute your mind that
doesn't respect someone's individuality
or you know freedom of thought or
expression right and that's what I
always say is the truth is that the
Democratic Party views us as low
information voters that's why they give
us Beyonce and jay-z they don't think
we're gonna go research the stature that
we're monitoring that sort of a thing
that's why when Hillary Clinton was on
these black hip-hop shows she was
talking about having hot sauce in her
bag don't talk to you about hot sauce
right in your back you know talk to you
about the issues that are facing our
community so I'm greatly insulted by the
fact people I'm her are you saying that
oh well there should be just more black
faces no there needs to be more but I
disagree with that
Greg enough says I I think that oh
what'd you say
Greg first I think that it goes beyond
politics but diversity is is something
that's real yeah symbols and reality
sometimes are the same wait wait but the
the ultimate result from the hyper
diversity is identity politics right
you're seeing you're not seeing the
individual anymore you're seeing the
group and I think that's what Kanye why
he connected with you was he was seeing
an individual talking about being an
individual not extolling the group
identity which has become so noxious
that we're putting the I mean the
quickest way to fascism is to put the
group before the individual what I mean
I'm hoping with what with Candis and and
looking at Kanye said now that you have
this power what do you do with it it's
about persuasion it's not it's it's like
you actually won now it's time to get
to win converts and that means being
persuasive which means not foregoing for
shock value but wanting to connect with
people who disagree with you and that's
what come when you saw Kanye and John
Legend going at it you saw two people
actually using love because they admire
each other while they deeply disagree
with over Trump and it worked and what I
think's happening now is the media
instead of covering the granular
conversation here they're trying to
discredit Kanye West because they don't
want to talk about Chicago or Barack
Obama you'd think that CNN when Kanye
West comes out and says something that's
shocking I mean it's not news if Kanye
had said something bad about President
Charlie I would not have been news but
CNN would have covered that all day long
the facts dead instead he says something
nice about President Trump and CNN and I
watched it either buried it or tried to
discredit Kanye so they're not being
fair with the way the news is being
provided I really want the conversation
actually agree but the fact of the
matter is black unemployment is at
record lows Hispanic unemployment is at
record lows that's the message that the
Republican Party has to convey to the
inner city that's a Daryl Scott in
Cleveland my neighbor and friend gets it
he spent you know you wee Republican
ideas are sometimes better than
democratic ideas the Democratic
establishment has you know presided over
the Camden's in the book that's the
thing it's the idea of persuasion like
you said Greg and you know Candace you
being part of that and so they can set a
friend of mine said instead of the
brexit the black cent movement meaning
it's okay to be black and proud and
conservative and a free thinker that was
my friend Rahim Kazan all right